est ce que vous connaissez la marque
vivo est ce que ça vous parle c'est une
marque qui est très connu dans le monde
entier mais qui vient d'arriver il ya
très peu de temps en france avec le
smartphone plutôt cool c'est le
smartphone qu'on trouve ici c'est le x
51 5 g alors le x 51 5 g eh bien
regardez il va vous faire le plein de
jolies promesses
à commencer par celle là là c'est la
photographie comme les appelle ça la
photographie mobile redéfinit voilà ils
redéfinissent les codes avec un système
de guînes ball guillemoles sais pas si
vous connaissez un système de
stabilisation en fait ça bien sûr sur
cinq axes qui vous permettra d'avoir des
vidéos notamment des vidéos hyper
stabiliser ans a bien évidemment jouer
aussi sur la photo et il vous avait
plein de mode qu'ils ont tous les
tailles et d'être sûr j'ai pas vous
faire lire aujourd'hui une documentation
sur le smartphone je vois pas trop la
taille par contre on va parler parce que
ce smartphone vous vous en douterez et
bien il est là je le teste je m'amuse
avec fait plein de trucs avec est en
fait ya plein de choses à raconter que
ce soit en termes de photos que ce soit
en terme de vidéo son terme de design en
termes d'écrans en termes de performance
les choix qui ont été faits deux dents
par vivo pour arriver avec un smartphone
qui se positionne lorsqu'elle est sortie
à 799 euros qu'on peut trouver
aujourd'hui moins cher à 699 d'ailleurs
s'il vous intéresse les amis des liens
en bas dans la description vous avez au
très grand module photo avec un game boy
sur la partie principale c'est un
capteur 48 mégapixels je vais tout vous
dire vous expliquez vous détailler vous
dire à quoi ça sert est ce qu'au final
cette marque que vous ne connaissez
peut-être pas encore aujourd'hui vivo
est ce qu'il faut se positionner est-ce
qu'il faut l'acheter est ce que le x 51
5 g est fait pour vous ou alors pas dû
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui réalisé
en partenariat avec zen zen qui est un
service de mastercard zèle est un
nouveau service qui vous permet
d'acheter sur internet en toute sécurité
vous pilotez zen depuis votre
application sur votre smartphone vous
vous inscrivez très facilement vous
pouvez disposer de 2 400 cas physique et
de cinq cartes virtuelles et elle vous
offre beaucoup de services pour nous
devons rassurer sur tous vos achats que
vous allez faire en ligne notamment une
extension de garantie de 1 an lorsque
vous avez fait vos achats et que votre
garantie est terminée bien si vous
arrive quoi que ce soit vous êtes
embêter zen venir vous rajoutez un an de
garantie
ça c'est très rassurant vous avez
également zenker za du caire est une
assurance gratuite sur les achats que
vous allez faire en ligne c'est par
exemple vous achetez un pro
et que vous en recevez une autre à la
place ou si le produit est défectueux et
bien zen va directement venir vous
rembourser comme ça au moins vous êtes
tranquille
il ya également un service de cashback
on va venir vous rembourser une partie
des achats que vous avez fait sur
internet auprès des sites partenaires et
si vous achetez dans des devises
étrangères vous voulez retirer de
l'argent lorsque vous êtes à l'étranger
et bien vous n'avez aucun frais
transaction et aucun frais bancaires
vous commandez votre carte bancaire
directement depuis l'application vous la
recevez chez vous vous pouvez venir
modifier vos plafonds venir bloquer la
carte très facilement vous pouvez donc
avoir une carte pour vos achats une
carte pour vos abonnements et si vous
avez la moindre question est le moins de
problème vous disposez d'un support en
ligne une application qui est disponible
sur ios mais également sur android vous
pouvez utiliser vos cartes avec apple
paix et google paye et vous avez deux
types d'abonnements un abonnement à 0 99
euros par mois c'est l'abonnement gold
et l'abonnement platinum à 4,99 par mois
et vous avez un mois d'essai gratuit du
service vous invite donc à venir
télécharger l'application est à vous
inscrire vous avez le lien en bas dans
la description d'exilés ouvrir lui dit
ah ouais ok très très très beau boulot
de la part de vivo vous avez un écran
incurvé qui prend quasiment toute la
face avant un petit point sont ici mais
bon voilà on est une fois de plus dans
les codes de 2020 donc y'a rien de bien
surprenant là dessus le bouton pour
l'allumer pour l'étendre des boutons de
volume très très classique également
haut parleur mono ici un seul
haut-parleur votre emplacement pour
votre double sim qui est ici votre
charge en usb c'est votre micro de ce
côté là absolument rien le micro pour la
réduction de bruit et surtout toute la
partie arrière avec vous le voyez ici le
module avec le petit guillaume ball qui
est vraiment ici ça c'est super chouette
j'aime beaucoup ça donne vraiment de la
gueule à ce smartphone deux modules
photos ici un troisième ici et ils vous
marquent la pro très cool
il ya un petit détail qui est très sympa
c'est qu'ici vous le marque 5 g
professional photographier ce qui est
très surprenant ici c'est que le dessus
et le dessous vont être complètement
plat donc si vous voulez vous amuser à
le poser en espérent qu'ils ne tombe pas
et bien vous pouvez le faire
un capteur d'empreintes digitales qui
est situé ici et qui déverrouille assez
rapidement ou également déroulé grâce à
la reconnaissance faciale
moi ce que j'aime beaucoup c'est un
format qui est très compact vous tenez
très très facilement une ma vie je peux
faire le tour ça c'est bien il est
relativement long la prise en main est
très bonne il est assez léger 181 g 5
vous avez un dos
envers maths et ce doha vers matt il a
la particularité de ne pas laisser de
traces de doigts donc ça c'est vraiment
super je conseille quand même devenir le
protéger pour éviter les déconvenues
mais malgré tout ça tout ça vraiment
vraiment vraiment très très bien une
seule couleur ici disponible c'est
l'alpha gray qui donne un côté très
futuriste hyper classe très premium à
l'avant ici vous retrouvez un écran
amoled qui dit et molettes dit samsung
c'est une dalle de 6,56 pouces avec un
taux de rafraîchissement de 80 diverses
résolutions 2376 par 1080 full hd plus
comme je vous le disais c'est un écran
qui est incurvé avec un échantillonnage
tactique de 180 m moi ce que j'aime bien
c'est que je trouve très lumineux très
très lumineux même d'ailleurs si je le
pousse à fond ça va vous faire mal aux
yeux voyez je peux monter jusqu'à 1300
dites moi ce que je viens vous
conseillez tout de suite si vous venez
d'acheter vous allez dans vos réglages
vous allez tout de suite dans affichage
et luminosité et vous allez donc
couleurs de l'écran par défaut il est
ici en mode standard je trouve qu'il
tire un petit peu trop sur le bleu moi
ce que je vous conseille c'est pas le
mode normal qui est je trouve un petit
peu de terre n'est pas terrible c'est le
mode lumineux saviem saturer un peu plus
mes couleurs
est ce que je vous conseille de venir le
réchauffé légèrement par ici et là pour
moi vous aurez la meilleure expérience
un tout petit peu plus chaud un tout
petit peu moins bleu parfait comme ça on
retrouve ici comme je vous le disais
uniquement un haut parleur mono ici pas
de haut parleurs stéréo
par contre si on parle en mon nom il
frappe il envoie du son une ovation
quand même plutôt pas mal n'a pas
particulièrement saturé l'expérience est
vraiment à gré
du contenu multimédia alors vous le
voyez la tenir vous mets dans mon image
devant légèrement mon petit but mon
petit point sont en vous le souhaitez
bombe factice à fès en 2020 si en plus
vous voulez aller beaucoup plus loin et
bien vous pouvez connecter un casque en
bluetooth wi avec du bluetooth 5.1
ici on regrettera l'absence de prise
jack mais une fois de plus dans ce
segment de prix et bien c'est devenu
aujourd'hui un grand standard donc rien
de bien anormal là dessus est à noter
que c'est également un smartphone qui
est certifié à erez audio au niveau de
la performance c'est un choix qui est
intéressant qui a été fait pas un niveau
ils ont fait le choix de ne pas mettre
le processeur le plus puissant actuels
sur le marché de qualcomm c'est à dire
laissant dragon 865 1865 plus
non ils vous ont mis un processeur
milieu haut de gamme c'est le 7 165 g g
pour immigrés alors ce processeur on a
déjà beaucoup parlé
il fonctionne très bien vous pourrez
faire tourner tous les jeux une pléthore
dessus sans souci néanmoins va pas boire
ce cas être plus performant il y avait
même une différence entre le 865 et le 7
165 g en termes d'autonomie en termes de
performances une fois de plus c'est
vraiment si vous venez le chercher dans
ses retranchements vous allez voir la
différence mais pour voir qu'on est sur
un smartphone qui à son lancement coûte
à un peu moins de 800 euros
ça reste assez surprenant de ne pas
avoir ce qui se fait de mieux en termes
de processeurs qualcomm ans nous
explique vivons ici c'est que ça allait
augmenter significativement les coûts je
pense que de la recherche et au
développement pour sortir un système de
guy moll comme ça qui coûte un peu cher
donc pour qu'il soit bien positionné
d'un point de vue tarifaire et bien il a
fallu faire des choix et ce notamment
pour ça qu'on retrouve sa dragonne 765
j'aime et qui marche très bien
soyez rassurez vous avez également 8
gigas de ram 256 go de stockage ici non
extensible il obtient la note de 331
1310 est sûr en tout tout ce que je vais
venir regretter un peu ici c'est le
classement pas su regarder si je le
trouvais faut que je remonte je remonte
je remonte je remonte je remonte pas il
est là 52e position s'avérer classé en
dessous du galaxy note dislike en
dessous du mx2 est ce voyage là quand
même pas mal de monde au dessus de lui
alors effectivement plus dire comme ça
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc
mais soyez tranquilles et soyez rassurez
moi j'ai testé une marche vraiment bien
pour les particuliers
il ira parfaitement bien s'affrontent ce
soir c'est quand même malgré toi c'est
puissant garde ou conçues pour le gaming
donc ici pas de surprise ça fera
parfaitement bien à faire ici niveau
nous avait une batterie du 4315
milliampères heures vous aller recharger
a su rapidement avec ce bloc de charge
de 33 watts via la banque qu'il a peints
voilà 33 watts vous le voyez ici
vous leurs charges et de 0 à 50 7 % en
une demi heure c'est un smartphone que
vous allez garder entre une journée à
une journée ni au niveau de l'autonomie
mais le point positif c'est que vous
aller recharger très rapidement grâce à
votre blog de charges 33 watts donc pas
d'inquiétude si vous manquez un petit
peu de batterie à un moment et bien vous
trouvez une prise un petit quart d'heure
et vous autres partis pour un bon moment
très efficace qui dit nouvelle marque
dit également nouvelle surcouche à
découvrir alors ici on tourne sur
funtouch qui est basé sur un android
iphone touch
rien de bien surprenant ici votre toutes
vos applications vous vous en douterez
vous avez votre tiroir d'applications
qui est juste ici ça c'est très très
cool
vous avez également de quoi faire
protection oculaire si vous souhaitez
activer pas activer désactiver et vous
avez bien évidemment tous vos paramètres
alors que c'est plutôt bien classé
plutôt intelligent assez bien fait ce
que j'aime bien notamment les effets
pour l'icône d'empreintes digitales
pouvait venir complètement personnalisé
également l'animation de reconnaissance
faciale ou encore l'animation de
rechargement ou alors l'animation
d'insertion usb je la trouve assez clair
devait également un mode ultra jeu mode
esport si vous le souhaitez on a donc
ici une expérience qui est complète
plutôt agréable côté photo ce que vivent
à nous proposer assez intéressant vous
le voyez si vous et votre capteur
principal 5,48 mégapixels ce un capteur
sony mx 5 198 ici on ouvre à f 1.6 en
anguille ball avec suspensions à double
vie qui n'est vraiment lui apporter une
stabilisation sur cinq axes ici juste en
dessous on retrouve son ultra
grand-angle qui vous parle également de
faire de la super macro on a un champ de
vision de 120 degrés pour la macro la
2.5 cm capteur 10 mégapixels on ouvre à
f 2.2 on a juste là ici un capteur de 13
mégapixels
c'est un objectif portrait teinté
objectif en fait qui ouvre à f 2.46 un
équivalente 50 mm
tu permettra d'avoir un zoom optique x 2
et juste ici en dessous on a un tel
objectif périscopique c'est un capteur
de 8 mégapixels couvre haifa 3.4 du zoom
optique x 5 et on va jusqu'à un hyper
zoom x 60 je manque le résultat dans
quelques instants tandis qu'à l'avant
d'une caméra de celle fille de 30 2
mégapixels et ouvre à f 2.45
le choix qu'a fait vivo ici au niveau de
la configuration photos vidéos et
extrêmement malines c'est une vraie
nouveauté apparaît vraiment de donner un
adn propre à ce smartphone parce que
même si le design est quand même assez
particulier est très bien fini ce qui va
vraiment dire nous intéresser ici et qui
sera le plus gros argument marketing
et bien c'est toute la partie photo qui
est vraiment mise en avant d'ailleurs
c'est là dessus qu'ils ont fait leur
slogan ils viennent - définir la photo
sur smartphone la photo est bien
évidemment la vidéo passe normalement un
bémol ça vraiment à venir améliorer pour
de la vidéo c'est tout l'intérêt
donc moi ce qui me plaît c'est le
triptyque c'est ce grand temps de 48
mégapixels positionné sur un guinebault
le fait d'avoir ce double téléobjectif
avec un côté un zoom périscopique et
l'autre côté un équivalent 50 mm pour
avoir un zoom optique x 2 ou 1 fois 5 et
l'idée également d'avoir cet ultra
grand-angle ça marche bien surtout il ya
un truc qui est très intuitif d'un point
de vue logiciel vous y retrouvez vos
modes un peu classique photo portrait
nuit on a vidéo et on a plein de modes
plus notamment pour venir pousser les
photos en 48 mégapixels un panorama lie
photo ralentis accélérés pro si on le
souhaite notamment super lune et le ciel
étoilé pour les photos de nuit et de
l'instantané mouvement ça c'est rigolo
il n'ya pas ma boîte double cliquer
dessus et bien je vais là look et
voiliers et ensuite je déplace je la
garde dans mon cas ça veut dire que je
garde le point dessus là je vous le
monde comme ça mais si par exemple les
gars je venais la rapprocher et bien
l'autofocus serait fait dessus et pas
sur autre chose ça permettra de faire
ici des photos pas des vidéos mais en
tout cas bon pourquoi pas assez assez
rigolo moi ce que j'aime bien c'est
l'expérience au niveau de la navigation
pour venir ou mais capteur principal
vous passez ensuite sur le téléobjectif
50 mm en faute de vous laisser appui
pourrait venir monter tout doucement
quand vous arrivez au x 5 et bien vous
passez sur le zoom périscopique et après
pouvait monte monte monte monte monte
jusqu'au x 60 voyez bon après ac c'est
un peu poussif
après j'ai pas une petite fonctionnalité
où je peux venir choisir ici super grand
angle le flou super macro la vraie
choisir votre mac row d'un point de vue
manuel mais si vous voulez faire de la
macro un peu classique et bien vous avez
qu à venir vous rapprocher à une
certaine distance et lui vie active et
la super macro et là on passe donc sur
l' ultra grand-angle sans s'en rendre
compte
ça c'est très très très très malin ici
on peut venir filmer 104 cas à 60 images
par secondes vous avez plein de
paramètres pour votre photo pour votre
stabilisation toute la partie vidéo est
aussi extrêmement intéressante parce que
là vous êtes un capteur principal
pouvait venir
mais un peu dans votre image en vidéo
vous avez également un mode super
stabiliser qu'une fonction anti secousse
avant c'est pourquoi pas et l'attaquent
vous pouvez passer sur notre
ultra-grand-angle si vous passez en mode
cinéma
voyez je tremble ce garçon qui tremble
je pensais quand même hyper hyper hyper
hyper stabiliser et ça ça marche
vraiment très très bien pour voir qu'ils
ont fait un gros focus au niveau de la
photo et de la vidéo sur son smartphone
eh bien voyez ici ils tiennent leurs
promesses la partie logicielle est très
très cool
il nous reste plus qu'à voir si les
résultats des photos et à la hauteur ou
alors pas du tout capteur principal je
trouve que globalement c'est plutôt pas
mal on voit bien le détail des nuages on
a bien l'art bus les arbres de ce
côté-là rien est cramé tout est juste
c'est vraiment bien bien maîtrisée de la
part de vivo luttera grand-angle et
simplement apprécié j'ai besoin de ça
lisse davantage au niveau du traitement
logiciel je retrouve du bruit ici le
long du bâtiment c'est tout de suite
moins cali mais une fois de plus sur un
ultra grand-angle rien de bien des cônes
en a pas de stabilisation
on voit ici voyez c'est très imparfait
au niveau de l'arbre on vient où mais se
rapprocher on est en x 2 ça me semble
pas trop trop mal franchement que ça
plutôt bien
le x 5 et bien a tendance à lisser on le
voit notamment ici au niveau de la
brique mais une fois de plus rien
d'anormal on se rapproche là on est en x
20 franchement ça fait le taf essaie
plutôt bien on récupère du bruit on le
voit dans le ciel d'un côté il n'y a
rien de magique et on finit au x 60
bon ces histoires 2 mais il n'y a pas
grand chose à exploiter paille capteur
principal c'est plutôt bien et on le
voit notamment ici avec tout ce qui
devrait également aux zones d'ombré
quand même plutôt bien éclairé plus
ressort plutôt bien donc le traitement
est très très juste
l'ultra grand pas qui jouera à peu près
les mêmes choses on en trouve du bruit
c'est imprécis c'est pas terrible
voilà pas génial génial le foie de ça
fonctionne
le x 5 pas trop mal le x 20 on peut et
le 60 on oublie je trouve que c'est
quand même assez lumineux et globalement
c'est vraiment tout ce qu'il m'a
vraiment vraiment surpris que ça capte
vraiment bien la lumière lutte racontant
un peu moins moyens mais bon ça le fera
à peu près le foie de très bien le x 5
et pas mal là le x 20 on le fait mais
bon voilà c'est pas trop trop fait pour
il faut 60 ces histoires de mais c'est
pour rigoler la caméra de celle fille et
je trouve assez honnête globalement
vraiment alors là en continu nous amener
un peu à la maison l'ambiance de noël
histoire de montrer des photos prises à
l'intérieur capteur principal lui
traduit en anglais grand-angle c'est
moins précis ya du bruit c'est pas
terrible
on se rapproche le x 2 2 x 5 mai il ya
moins de lumière c'est pas terrible et
on le voit stock salissant vraiment
paris six voiliers au niveau du
traitement
on continue au x 20 bon voilà c'est un
mois histoire de alors un peu de
maquereaux écoutez c'est pas trop trop
mal franchement parce qu'on passe par le
capteur ultra grand-angle le résultat
est pas mauvais maintenant allez vous en
faire pour autant je ne suis pas sûr
mais vu ce qu'on peut retrouver en macro
fort ici le rendu est globalement assez
juste le mode portrait et fois c'est
assez bizarre autant il arrive bien à
détourer ils vous ressemblent bien les
choses mais par contre ça vous lis le
visage et un côté un peu cadavérique pas
très naturel si vous voulez vous pouvez
mais bon rendu pour moi c'est pas
exceptionnel alors la photo de nuit
c'est un tout qui est vachement
intéressant la route aux nuits pris seul
capteur principal on vient se rapprocher
en fois de l'ultra grand temps que la
nuit vous l'oubliez vous allez voir
plusieurs photos et mathieu qui me plaît
vraiment c'est sale c'est l'option ciel
étoilé c'est assez dingue
franchement on est en pleine nuit il
fait noir je ne vois pas ça dans le ciel
et là franchement ça me bluffe
réellement réellement sans bluff
il vaudrait mieux mettre sur un trépied
point que vous ne bougez pas du tout
mais le résultat est vraiment au rendez
vous quel est le principal ça marche
le foie de bons vite fait si on veut
l'ultra grand angle on oublie la nuit là
on n'est pas en mode ciel étoilé juste
sur une photo de nuit ça me sort un truc
assez dingue avec le ciel genevois pas
donc j'ai d'un côté ma scène avec tout
ce qui éclairait qui est très juste et
je vois ça au dessus franchement c'est
vraiment bluffant et un côté un peu fake
parce que c'est parce qu'on voit en vrai
mais par contre il ya vraiment un effet
what the fuck c'est waouh c'est vraiment
pas mal
l'ugtt racontant l'on n'oublie salissent
là je les fais la même avec vous des
ciels étoilés font pas grand grande
différence avec le côté de lui un peu
plus classique pareil capteur principal
luttera grand-angle on oublie caméra
principale c'est pas mal à garder l'oeil
sur les arbres là que ça me sort en
détail
il ya un côté un peu tim burton je
trouve au niveau de l'ambiance mais
j'aime bien j'aime beaucoup luttera
vente angle on oublie ciel étoilé une
fois de plus beauf au delà stable parce
que sinon c'est pas extraordinaire
moi je suis assez bluffé honnêtement par
le rendu des photos de nuit sur le
capteur principal et par l'idée du ciel
étoilé je trouve ça vraiment bien c'est
très très très bien maîtrisée de la part
de vivo le rendu est assez what the fuck
caméra principale sera très bien
ultra-grand-angle si vous avez beaucoup
de lumière le x 2 x 5 cm à bien jusqu'au
x 20 hockey en pleine journée lorsque la
lumière et le reste x 60 c'est vraiment
le temps de se marrer parce que bon
c'est pas extraordinaire
kimball l'afrique c'est assez
impressionnant c'est quand même hyper
bien stabilisée vers des lâches et des
mouvements un peu d'où vous lâchez les
mouvements brusques
c'est vachement et surtout avec moi un
qui tremble je puis vous assurer que ça
s'est vraiment bien alors il ya un autre
mode qui est encore plus stabilisée avec
une fonction anti secousse avancé et
ouais je dois reconnaître que c'est
vraiment bien dans les cages marche
c'est quand même pas mal
vous allez retrouver ici une double
carte nadeau sim une 5 g et une kadjé
vous pouvez pas voir ici double carte 5
g ça sera possible grâce au sein dragon
888 il faut donc s'armer de patience et
attendre encore un petit peu quelques
mois pour que ça puisse arriver enfin
sur vos smartphones et c'est un
smartphone qui comme je vous le dis tout
tarif de 799 euros l'an sa sortie quand
vous trouvez aujourd'hui un peu moins
cher à 699 euros
moi ce que j'aime bien et si c'est le
choix qui a été fait par vivo au niveau
de la photo très bel argument marketing
ils savent de toute façon vivo que les
photos c'est aujourd'hui un des usages
les plus importants sur smartphone
les usagers sont claires aujourd'hui sur
les smartphones ça va être un très très
bel écran pour venir visionner du
contenu multimédia notamment netflix
prime vidéo et compagnie ils savent
également que ce qui compte c'est le
gaming le gaming est très très puissant
nous ont mis un processeur dédié gaming
même si ce n'est pas le plus performant
il fera très bien la faire et surtout
les usages photo qui est aussi un des
usagers sens et donc le support noah ils
viennent cocher les cases en smartphones
qui est plutôt bon ce que je viens à
regretter ici c'est de pouvoir compter
sur un smartphone haut de gamme
on a absolument aucune certification de
résistance à l'eau et à la poussière
ça fait un peu râler ce qui pourrait
poser problème non pas de vue
intellectuel plus que d'un point de vue
vraiment pratique s'est fait de ne pas
avoir le processeur le plus puissant de
qualcomm
néanmoins le 7 165 g marche bien
et une fois de plus ce qui est toujours
un peu dur également c'est ce qu'on va
retrouver en face à la concurrence
puisque problème tarif vous aurez des
processeurs plus puissants mais vous
n'aurez pas l'innovation duguine ball
il faut donc savoir ce que vous voulez
ce qui pourrait vous intéresser ce que
vous comptez faire de la vidéo avec
votre smartphone ou pas si vous comptez
faire de la vidéo et de vos smartphones
et bien ça c'est vraiment une super
solution d'ailleurs dit moi vous est-ce
que vous pensez que ce smartphone
pourrait correspondre à vos usages et
quel visage vous en auriez plutôt
multimédia visionnage de séries films
plutôt gaming plutôt photo mark et moi
ça en bas en commentaire pour heymans
rendre compte si au final ce smartphone
vous correspondre vous invite à me
marquer tout ça en bas en commentaire de
long se trouve extrêmement rapidement
pour continuer à parler tech parce que
oui vous le savez on a peur que ça
comptait beaucoup d'actu et même en
cette période de fêtes de fin d'année
beaucoup d'amour il ya très vite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]